una lucha por salvar a la reina
una laguna cerca de Caracas en Venezuela
cuya gran biodiversidad está en peligro
por la deforestación y la contaminación
que que comprende nuestra laguna no
sabían porque de niños fueron criados
con una cultura de que no valía la pena
Pues los mangles aquí en nuestra
comunidad eran como decís madera para
para producir casas piojos Pero entonces
lo veían Como esos nada más ahora los
habitantes de sus Riberas promueve la
educación ambiental con un proyecto de
conservación llamado una corona para la
reina financiado por el programa de las
Naciones Unidas para el desarrollo
una ong ecobrión lucha entre otros temas
para que no se construya un puente más
elevado que daría paso en la laguna a
embarcaciones de mayor calado tiene que
ver con el tema de la construcción de
carreteras y vías por los espacios de la
laguna las viviendas multifamiliares o
complejos urbanísticos la disposición en
adecuada desechos sólidos la laguna de
120 hectáreas está conectada a la playa
Valle seco cuya línea costera ha
retrocedido al menos 30 metros en la
última década debido al cambio climático
la alcaldía declaró en 2009 este lugar
monumento natural pero a pesar de los
esfuerzos sus orillas son usadas como
vertederos de basura los activistas
buscan que tanto sus habitantes como los
que visitan el lugar tengan conciencia
de su entorno y le devuelvan el reino
que le pertenece a la laguna